les chéris il ya une nouvelle
chroniqueuse parmi nous elle est
magnifique il sera pas se mentir
très jolie elle est jeune elle est jeune
et jolie et fraîche elle est fraîche
elle est fraîche comme la rosée du matin
elle est fraîche comme un homme qui
partiraient à la chasse cette personne a
une particularité
alors attention pour lui poser toutes
les questions avec moi je moi je vais
pas jouer pas exactement je sais je sais
qui c'est d'accord même si j'avais pas
su qu'ils s'étaient j'aurais trouvé
alors pas très bien je dirais pourquoi
après merci mais dira pourquoi après
attend attention poser les questions
elle répondra par oui ou non au pari s
en eau ou par yarol rniste elle est
insolente
j'aime bien les l'aiim est ce que vous
êtes une fille ou un garçon
alors comment grâce à une chaîne youtube
non non est ce qu on vous connaît grâce
à une chaîne youtube du mena ça n'est
pas la bonne question
jean michel lemaire est ce que vous avez
gagné un concours de cris de nouveaux
noms mais pourquoi vous savez faire un
animal ou pas bah non mais pourquoi je
cherche moi je tâtonne
parce qu'il est ici il ya souvent des
mecs qui avaient qui limite des clés
d'animaux qui viennent y sera de ce prêt
n'ont eu qu'un spectacle imiter les
mythiques aux 10 h à un moment une
féerie des eaux
non mais vraiment alors oui est ce que
vous êtes journaliste
mais nan nan est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
sur les listes quoique si elle était
journaliste ou pas mais en fait tout
sauf si ça peut ouvrir
il cherche le buzzer géraldine m'a dit
que vous êtes française oui d'accord
d'accord alors dieu merci les français
es ce que vous avez vos papiers
jean luc est ce que vous êtes déjà fait
de la télé non non attention mettez est
ce qu'on vous a pas déjà vu d'un touche
pas à mon poste
non vous avez déjà vu cette voie vous
connaissez touche pas à mon poste et
demi beaucoup de jeunes filles jolies
qui sont déjà venus doit donc de lui
demander ce qu'il avait déjà vu dans
touche pas à mon poste
ben oui comment vous êtes henri iv
d'amnésie non mais elle a confié qu
rachid arhab à la première jambe
hadjamar castaldi est ce que vous avez
un nom connu
we had callahan ont connu un oui à c'est
une fille castadi encore
ça reste assez vague pour manille alors
gérer non géraldine maillet est-ce que
vous travaillez dans un cirque est ce
que vous êtes contorsionniste par
exemple filles bouillonnent c'est quoi
c'est que voyez-vous la compagnie
contemponi oui c'est vrai wen et tout ça
allait on va renter au laurier question
design est est ce que vous êtes là la
vie d'une personne très connue alors
c'est la fille de quelqu'un s'est senti
mal alors voilà à la halde à l'imper à
l'ail mer ok il est très connu en plus
très connu et très connue très très
connu et les cherry pour être tissés
dans un instant jouer regardez là bon
sens oui oui on a même dit quelque chose
dans un instant je vous dirais de kesha
j'ai enfin on ira de qui il s'agit et je
vais vous dire c'est parents ne savent
pas qu'elle est ici sonore voir donc je
les appellerai en direct pour leur mire
alors êtes vous majeur déjà les majors
et les majeures je les appellerai pour
leur dire ce qu'ils sont
son son papa moi je vous dis très très
très connu et je l'appellerai en direct
parce qu'il n'est pas du tout mais c'est
bien son papa graphie oui taf unis et
dans l'émission ce soir
voilà sa réaction s'il arrive et qui me
pète la gueule eh ben je vous dise pour
l'instant on cherche une personne qui
est ici bonsoir vous avez pris le livre
voilà vous appelez votre prénom c'est
carla est en fait c'est c'est carla
bruni non alors qu'ils aient quart là
avant la pause
vous vous disais que c'est une personne
qui a un papa très connu
et son papa ne sait pas qu'elle est là
ce soir je vais vous raconter la
productrice de l'émission agatha roulant
l'a amené ce matin au bureau on a fait
une petite entretien avec agata elle et
je lui dis ce soir tu à l'antenne est ce
que ton père est au courant elle m'a dit
non ils ne savaient même pas que vous
venez vous voir ça promet on va
l'appeler doré un instant pour lui dire
qu'on détient sa fille
alors qui est cette personne cd si vous
avez d'autres questions aujourd'hui
alors ça sympa faire un vin salle
recherche mais est ce que vous vous
rendez compte qu'en venant ici vous
allez subir un dîner en tête à tête avec
maxime gainey à la cantine
exactement maxime est ce que c'est votre
style oui bah oui
[Applaudissements]
afin de faire il fait le ramadan tout
cas c'est le ramadan débute le garçon la
tête de ma mère c'est un paquet frère
mais c'est bien d autres carla et kelly
c'est comme ça alors entre votre j'ai
rien vu dépasser ce qu'elle dit car là
alors car la question de benjamin
castaldi
on a parlé d'un pape à ses lèvres oui
est-ce qu'il est comédien non non et
ceux qui travaillent dans l'univers de
la télévision
maintenant oui alors ma bb n'a alors
pena ont benhaim on vous rappelle
maintenant donc il il avait un autre
métier avant était footballeur il était
footballeur masson jean pierre papin la
fille de david ginola
david ginola
[Applaudissements]
mais franchement est la famille la wii
la famille est très belle mais on va pas
se borner à regarder papa cheveux même
rapport à vie mais david ne sait pas
qu'elle est ici je rappelle que david
ginola en plus va démarrer sur m6 me baï
d'ailleurs il est jeune et déjà sur m6
après va faire incroyable talent sur m6
on va appeler david ginola tout de suite
pour lui dire que sa fille est ici je
vous jure qu'il n'est pas au courant
c'est parti on l'appelle j'ai même pas
bien le prendre ils veulent prendre à ce
que j'ai pas envie de me faire jaser
vêtements en direct et en france là il
est en france oui ça sonne français ça
sonne français comme disait florian
philippot évidemment alors alors
troisième sonnerie je rappelle que la
valise rtl pour d'habitude et à 1240
kato un ancien footballeur et le pont
ballot à l'eau david à changer de volant
david ginola
c'est cyril hanouna le l'animateur
basané pakistanais bonsoir à vous êtes
vous êtes passé à l'eau oui j'avais
compris que halo on est toujours bien on
évolue téléphonique je garde mon cap
béar c'est cyril on est en direct à la
télé je suis avec je suis avec quelqu'un
que vous connaissez peut-être pas que
lui connaît
david lille 1 on en direct sur ces huit
manches eric comment ça va ça va ça va
et toi mon grand tu es en forme
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya dessus je suis à la
télé dans cinq minutes
alors justement mon chéri avant que tu
passes à la télé je voulais juste te
dire qu'ils se tuent cherche sa fille
allait avec moi sur le plateau mais non
je ne jure elle avec moi sur le plateau
frérot t'inquiète pas je m'en occupe
bien mais si ça vole très bien j'espère
t'inquiète pas inquiète pas d'accord je
suis un david je m'en occupe la pierre
ménès qui est là aussi tu me fais
confiance perron
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]